let's get creative check out this fun  idea  christmas why can't we find you hi drew  let's let the whole neighborhood know  we're ready for the holidays so we need  a foam wreath led lights and some coffee  filters from our local discount store on  a low heat setting glue those led lights  all the way around your wreath then take  your coffee filters wrap them around a  pencil put a dab of hot glue and dab dab  dab all the way around the wreath fill  that in with the coffee filters it's  gonna be full and gorgeous ah look at  that light it up  fabulous  take a bow glue that to the wreath as  well and then hang that on your front  door and the whole neighborhood knows  it's christmas time at our house love  craft grooms that's  genius why didn't i think of that  [Music]